okay great so for the final talk of
today I think
um
speak about some recent work on unifying
algorithms for multi-calibrations
um thank you
um yeah I'm really excited to be here to
give this talk usually I give a talk
that's more about the motivation of why
we should care about certain things but
I feel like we've got a lot of
motivation for why we should be caring
about multi-calibration and fairness so
what I thought is there's very little
kind of big big picture as to why we
should care about these things and I'm
approaching this talk as somewhat of a
mini tutorial it's a very general
approach to designing algorithms for
these settings that we've already agreed
that we do care about multi-calibration
group furnace and a number of other
settings
so
I know that
nevertheless I will have like two
minutes of motivations can't can't you
know can't not do that
um so we've definitely seen this like uh
Cartoon example multiple times and also
just kind of General motivation for the
fact that while we're having more data
also this data is representing much more
diverse groups of people and we are
using it in decision making for more and
more diverse and also fine-grained types
of guarantees that we're looking for so
this is a type of a cartoon example that
we might have seen we have different
hospitals maybe there are actually
representing different types of
population some uh people with older age
some maybe minorities some women and we
want to make sure that actually the
types of decisions that we are making
and for these different types of people
are somewhat equally good
um in a way that we're not going to be
making decisions that are completely
um high quality for some group and much
worse for the other
and what this means is that we are going
to be looking at beyond the typical
types of on average type guarantees that
are so common in machine learning
because we do know that machine learning
with on average guarantee works really
well what that means is that you're
giving guarantees that don't hold for
specific X y's but for an expectation
with high probability when X Y is drawn
from some distribution but the issue is
that while that's definitely good when
our data is homogeneously like separated
like data centers one is actually people
and organizational data this is not the
case anymore and it's very we've already
seen examples again not even cartoon
examples where once you look within the
subgroups some subgroups are
outperforming others
so what can we do if we want to go above
Beyond this average and what are the
learning difficulties that we should be
aware of the difficulties we should be
aware of are that different subgroups
actually pose different types of
challenge in terms of some have more
data some have less data but also some
data is just much more easily to
classify it just looks much more
homogenous within some groups and other
data looks
um much more messy so what we need to do
is to be able to learn these settings
without really paying way above and
beyond what we would have been paying
for a single distribution kind of like
what Daniel was also talking about
trying to relate these things so also
like what would have happened if it was
just a single population
I'm going to give you two examples the
first one is something we've seen a lot
and the second one is somewhat closer
again to what Daniel talked about
um the first one is calibration I know
at this point I don't need to introduce
what calibration is at all so this is
making sure that your predictions are
consistent
um and we did see two versions of this
this I feel like I'm making in
caricature of this but again let's go
with the toy version of thinking as
calibration over existing data sets
rather than online calibration in a way
that Dean talked about
where it could be a rather weak
guarantee whereby just guessing you know
the expected label your satisfying
calibration guarantees
completely meaningless on any individual
X on the other hand we have the per
group version of calibration that we've
been talking about throughout this
Workshop this is the multi-calibration
are there different ways to write
multi-calibration the way I've written
it here is with kind of expectation of
label conditional on PX
kind of being close to they should be
kind of close to v v v being the
predicted value and S being assault
populations from sub set of
subpopulations that were given to us
the second example I want to give where
again we go from something that's
classical and on average to something
that's per group is about agnostic
learning or binary classification
regression doesn't really matter where
now you're not necessarily learning an
arbitrary predictor you're given a
function class and you're predicting
based on that function class this could
be a zero one function and you have a
loss which could be a splinter
classification or regression loss again
we have the classical pack or agnostic
setting that says that on average I want
to have a good error so I want my
expected error population to be close to
Epsilon or Epsilon cross opt
and it's problematic again if you want
to have it mean anything because and
something that has over five percent
could mean that on some one-tenth of the
population has over 50 so that's again
the problematic version of interpreting
these classical results
what is it per group guarantee versions
of this many different formalizations
when everything is pack learnable all of
them actually kind of
go down to one version where we are
thinking that
you have multiple groups maybe they're
represented by just different
distributions this you can think about
your distribution D condition on top
sets of people or you can just think
about it as actual distributions D1 to
Decay and then you're asking for a loss
that's near optimal for every group so
this is again closer a little bit to
what Daniel was talking about
I can give you more examples but I think
two is enough for a 30 minute talk so
what do we want out of this I've shown
two examples when we are going from
single to multiple distributions or
multiple objectives and what we really
want is to be to enable these learning
processes they can satisfy multiple
objectives and learn over multiple
distributions but from collectively few
or sample points and data so what you
want is to really make sure that sample
complexity is not blowing up crazy and
while we have seen that this has a lot
of relationship fairness I think there
are two other things that we shouldn't
forget this is also a very classical
robustness question I'll give some
citations and also a data sharing and
Collaborative Learning application so
beyond fairness there's actually a lot
of other applications we should be
thinking about
what am I going to do in this talk it's
a mini slash micro tutorial on
statistical foundations of
multi-objective learning I'll try to hit
three things first one is I mean what is
multi-objective learning as one unifying
framework and then how does
multi-calibration look like in the
multi-objective setting
how do you solve multi-objective
settings what are different ways of
solving it and what are optimal ways of
solving it and then hopefully I will
have time to go beyond calibration and
talk about multi-objective learning from
for other group furnace
multi-distribution settings again
touching more closely related to the
last stock and some of the other stuff
you see
so what is multi-objective learning I'm
going to define the following approach
to thinking about multiple groups in
learning
think about the setting I was talking
about multiple hospitals each one has
its own distribution so we have a bunch
of distributions D1 to DK
um and we can sample from these
distributions I can choose B2 and take
10 samples from it
we might also have different objective
functions or loss functions L1 to LR
what is L well L could be anything
really but I think for the purpose of
this talk and especially because of
multi-calibration let's think about L
that really relates to calibration so
while it could be like the binary loss
you could also kind of think about it
more generally as oh maybe it's also
something that looks kind of like
prediction value as well being put into
the loss and then we're thinking about
expected value of these losses
then what we say is multi-objective
learning is if you can simultaneously
learn a single function f that is
simultaneously good for every population
and every objective what does this mean
well one way to write this is to hope
that there's indeed a function that
would for every J and every d i be less
than Epsilon because
essentially if I didn't have these two
Maxes this L J D I would have been the
pack learning setting or the calibration
setting but by adding multiple
distributions on multiple objectives
um I'm asking for the worst case
guarantees to be really good no matter
which loss function and what
distribution
this is uncovering a universally good
model
always it's not always guaranteed
sometimes you just don't have a good
function class like maybe the function
class you're allowed to be like to take
functions from or just not expressive
enough
so more General way of expressing this
is to bring the min max value so what
does that do you have something that
you're guaranteeing and you want this
guarantee to be as good as possible
compared to the best option you have in
class the best option is that men of H
and H star or men of H star NH
this is the best in class guarantee of
this
um I was planning to skip this but
just very briefly let me say that while
I wrote the min max
there's a bunch of other ways of
thinking about this problem like
specifically what Daniel actually showed
where you are thinking about
generalization error that is also
enabled by this perspective while it
might not look obvious from the first
side so this is just kind of saying that
this does relate a little bit more
generally so don't get hung up on maybe
I don't want men to be here maybe I
wanted to be somewhere else
okay
so what does multi-calibration look like
in the setting I have some loss
functions in the settings so multi
calibration better now talk about these
losses like I have to actually create a
function class create bunch of losses so
that if you're satisfying
multi-objective you're satisfying
multi-calibration
what does this look like it's a simple
exercise but there's a point to this
that becomes more clear because I think
about this as a unifying perspective so
what is this exercise doing
it says that think about all predictors
as your function class so if it's binary
predictions your P of X is anywhere
between zero one
and now think about losses that are
calibration style losses what do these
losses do they take they take a subgroup
s and they take a predicted value B
for the second ignore Sigma what they
say is that well what's a loss if you
could say condition but you could also
say that if I just focus on the
distribution of x's where I predicted
almost B so that's my predicted value
um and X belong to the set pass so
that's exactly calibration and Y minus P
of X is how far off your
this Sigma plus minus 1 is to say that
if you overestimate or underestimate
both of them are bad you should like you
can't play with underestimating
so if you say it say this that way then
whenever you satisfy multi-objective
learning which is now this you're
actually going to be an S Epsilon
multi-calibrated predictor okay
I wrote this as min max because I want
you to get used to seeing in Max but
this is actually zero since the base
outcome classifiers perfectly calibrated
perfectly multi-calibrated
this is how you would write
multi-calibration as multi-objective
um there's another a very common
um application this is related to pack
learning where again this is an example
of multi-objective learning instead of
thinking about too many objectives you
think about many different distributions
and then you ask the same thing you're
given a Class 8 as opposed to
constructing it
and then you're given a bunch of
distributions and what you want is to
make sure that the worst case uh
distributions loss is not much worse
than the min max
um
you said a quick caveat about sort of
flipping men versus bets in the
Minister well so is there yeah yeah so
so
um
I'm just trying to make sure so okay
for a fixed hypothesis class wouldn't I
want so more like Daniel was saying
wouldn't it be Matt Smith depends what
you are asking for so if you do this
let's just say that they collapse if
they share beta optimal classified let's
first agree on that
if they share if distributions share a
okay so now the trick is that most of
the times that you get these like really
nice guarantees what's happening is that
there's a relationship between the base
optimal classifier so what I can do is
to write for example what Daniel wrote
slightly differently and get this out of
it solve this and get that so it's a
little bit out of the scope of what I'm
going to talk about in the next 15
minutes but I can give some
um some explicit citations for this
appendices where this thumbs up
would you also get well for the multi
for the calibration there's no is there
a multi here yeah oh it's for all the s
and would you get the same result would
you would it be possible to just fix H
to be the constant classifiers
and classifiers yeah as in like you
don't take accents with them
I mean
um this wouldn't be right anymore
because you want to include at least
your base classifier right
I guess for the calibration loss there
was always a constant classifier that
achieved zero error
it's offline I see so so you're thinking
about an online no but for
multi-calibration you can't right
imagine if your ass was each individual
X
then truly you have to be the base
optimal classifier
so yeah I think I think you're thinking
about Max Smith
you've said it's okay
I'm thinking about that this guy is
awesome okay cool
okay so I said that this is I think
about this as not just a point of
exercise but as a unifying perspective
and I know we don't have a lot of time
but let me just put a whole bunch of
words and there's one that doesn't
include like just doesn't fit you've
seen already three of them
multi-calibration of course you've seen
uh Roth blam Yona Daniel was just
talking about it
um I believe this work has been
mentioned I don't know how much we
focused on it
but these three works I think is good to
know about because this is about group
distribution robust optimization that's
the connection to robustness I was
talking about connection to Federated
learning and agnostic learning and
connection to Collaborative Learning
um Collaborative Learning actually
um all these three become one while
these three slightly are different
the point here is to say that if you're
going to focus on multi-objective rather
than in any single one of these settings
how would we approach solving them from
a systematic perspective and then can we
generalize these approaches across the
different
um types of you know different bullets
point bullet points in fact and for
calibration in particular which is going
to be the main focus what I find is
perspective to really help is that it
does improve some of the non-guarantees
but I don't think that's the main point
of this that is not my main purpose for
studying this in this way but it's
because we tend to know how to in theory
we do better when we stand on the
shoulders of giants and the approaches
that I'm going to at least give you are
about very general very well studied
forms of optimizations that hopefully we
can kind of build up on and create a
better understanding that that
generalizes to more difficult and
complex tasks in multi-class higher
moments and online and adaptive and XYZ
type of multi calibration
so how did it go from
um
no I don't have a lot of time but
this is to say the point Daniel was
saying we want to solve the malted
version of this but let's not lose the
site of the single version of this no
matter what both in terms of sample
complexity but also in terms of insights
I think it's really important not to
lose that sign
so what is this kind of a more General
way of solving multi-objective problems
the reason I focus on this min max min
max even though not all of you love it
is because min max is oh sorry this
shouldn't be here it's just us
is
um a very general perspective once you
have something that looks min max you'll
know what's the first step to solving it
what is the first step you think about
it as a game between a minimizing agent
and a maximizing agent the minimizing
guys trying to reduce this loss over the
choice of his action set and the
maximizing agent is maximizing the same
loss over now her choice of actions
and what we know is that essentially
what you're after is something that is
Satisfied by a notion of approximate min
max equilibrium and forget about exactly
what this means the point is that this
is related to a literature on Game
Theory that's very well studied and then
how do we actually go about finding
equilibria there are very generic ways
of finding them and essentially they
boil down to making sure that one of
your players is playing a No Regret
algorithm while the other one has a lot
more freedom either they can do no
regret best response they can do
anything that's not super naive
so this kind of opens up at least three
different types of Dynamics
both doing no regret or one of one or
the other guy doing the no regret
so I just kind of I'm going to be
talking about regret and I know I'm not
the first person but I want to know who
here
um was familiar with regret before
coming to the workshop this week
perfect so I don't have to go in into a
lot of details
um but I will still just do the very
minimal just to Prime you think about it
in a certain way I talked about best
response and no regret let's clarify
what they mean best response means that
per time step you're actually choosing
something that was optimal for that time
step okay
um no regret means that over many time
steps the choices that you made were
near optimal kind of in hindsight
comparative fix fixed option
um no matter what the other player
played
so what no regret for multi-calibration
loss that I wrote down looks like for
the minimizing player this is the guy
who's learning the predictor is he is
not regret if he learns P1 P2 PT in an
online way given kind of the adversarial
choices over which subgroup which
predicted value and over versus
underestimation
the loss the calibration loss now the
multi-calibration loss is very small
this is again I wrote it as Min but this
is again zero if P was base so this is
saying that
um no matter what populations popped up
on average you did quite well in terms
of your multi-calibration loss
the maximizing player is the adversarial
person who is picking the subpopulations
the predicted values on over and
underestimation
and he has no regret if he is
essentially maximizing that loss maybe
minus a tiny bit
so what we do know about these things
and we've known him done for decades
um is that first of all generic no
regard algorithms exist they exist in
the sense that there are root t log of
the number of actions available to you
and that the how quickly we get to the
solution concept that min max that I was
talking about is a really a function of
how quickly these two regrets shrink So
the faster they shrink the better it is
okay what are some unique challenges to
multi-calibration now well
one main challenge is that in general we
don't see distribution equally we can
just sample from it
in general no regard algorithms need to
know what laws they're playing with so
we need to make sure that we can play no
regret without taking too many samples
this affects the minimizing player in
two ways
he he might do best response which means
that we need to compute a predictor
that's calibrated for whatever choice
that came up but without too many
samples
it also affects the No Regret version of
this
the same way again we don't want to take
too many samples
um but there are some other things that
also become important in particular that
whether PT itself has to be randomized
or could it be deterministic and that's
because at the end of the day for
calibration we would love to have
something that's a deterministic
predictor rather than a random predictor
random predictors calibration they don't
go very well together
for maximizing player a similar kind of
challenge exists can we do this without
too many samples and this is the ideal
part which is the Dynamics that I
technically showed you is taking time
average predictor so technically it's
randomized we need to make sure we can
extract the terminals
these are three different types of
challenges
the minimizing guide the learner
the maximizing guy and determinism I'm
going to mostly focus on this because if
you figure out figure out how to do this
the other two actually somewhat come
naturally
so I'm going to talk about how you can
make sure that you have a calibrated
less response and no regret now really
go to tiny tiny bit of detail the first
thing is that the best response is
something that was figured out a while
ago in fact you can use some of the work
from uh Dean's work and or
or if you want
um Sergio's perspective on this that
says that you could actually compute if
I give you a distribution over the the
loss like the subgroup and the predicted
value and all of that you could without
looking at the distribution actually
have something that's multi-calibrated
so this is like point-wise guarantee and
intuitively the reason this is something
you could do is actually very similar to
the reason that uh you could calibrate
in an online fashion for an Adaptive
adversary so pretty related
the second thing that I want to actually
better understand is a No Regret version
of this
the No Regret version says that for an
adversarial sequence of else
um you could construct this predictor PT
that has three properties first is
deterministic the top one didn't
couldn't be deterministic
second it takes no samples from D just
like the top one
third is Regret is independent of X
importantly but it has a very particular
form square root of t log of the number
of labels
and at a very high level I'm making a
bigger claim in fact my claim is that
take any no regret algorithm that can
handle k number of actions we have
generic ones hedge whatever you want to
call it
then such an algorithm will give you a
deterministic online calibrated
predictor and by calibrated I mean with
respect to the way I Define the No
Regret version in the last slide
why is this the case in some sense what
you're doing is that for each X you
ignore the fact that X's are different
and you like sorry you treat that X
individually
and interpret this predictor as itself a
distribution over K actions
okay
so what this means is that it's as if PT
itself and no regard algorithm is it's
putting this distribution over K things
now each of these actions has a very
particular form of loss and that loss
for example in binary prediction if I
think about PT as the probability of
predicting action one versus action zero
then the prediction loss is going to be
the calibration loss the way I Define
that okay it's for whatever VT and sdn
sigma T that the adversary picked the
adversary is picking these losses
if you said it this way what happens is
that the expected calibration loss of
each X is the expected regret this is
the expected prediction loss and
therefore regret becomes from prediction
like on K actions becomes regret in this
so this is very general for any no
regard algorithm
so what does this help us with it gives
us
two Dynamics I can do the best response
Dynamic this is not the ideal Dynamic
but let's see what it looks like the
maximizing player is going to be the No
Regrets guy and his regret is not that
bad you know
the minimizing player is going to be the
best response this is the one I was
saying that it's randomized but you
don't take a single sample
the maximizing player is going to need
some samples to estimate imagine that
it's taking a single sample
then what happens is that we can show
that the randomized predictor that's
uniform over P1 to PT is going to be S
Epsilon multi-calibrated after these
many time steps which is exactly the
inversion of the regrets that I was
talking about
what's bad about this the fact that it's
a non-deterministic predictor but it's
good because it's fast
let me switch who's playing no regret
and who's playing best response because
now I can do that I have both
let's say the maximizing player is
picking best response to whatever the
minimizing player did
the minimizing player
is doing uh no regret I think I didn't
write that yeah
that sorry the minimizing player is
doing deterministic no regret without
sampling
then we know that the randomized
predictor is going to be doing well but
in fact we know something more
the randomized predictor is doing well
it means that on average one of these
pts is doing well
and since each one of them was
deterministic there is indeed a
deterministic one
in this set that I learned that's a good
predictor it's an S Epsilon
multi-calibrated predictor so this gives
a deterministic and fast convergence
let me say that this is the example you
saw from Michael's talk yesterday
and it you can kind of interpret it in
the way that I wrote this is doing the
best response in fact this is a weak
best response we could deal with weak
best response rather than thinking about
the adversary doing exact optimization
and this is a very particular no regret
algorithm this is gradient descent but
you could actually replace it with any
other no regret outboard
so why Embrace a non-regular Dynamics
well the benefits of using this
multi-objective thing is that I said it
unifies and simplifies but it also
matches and improves existing results so
for example
for let me see which ones are included
for for K class calibration rather than
just two classes the classical bound
used to be polynomial in K you can get
logarithm making K if you replace
gradient descent with like
exponentiated gradient is a bit h
you could also just simplify and improve
bunch of other results I don't have time
to go into them
but it also allows you to go beyond
multi-calibration the way it's been
studied there's a bunch of other
variants that are a little bit
understudied some of them have been
studied to some degree agnostic
multi-calibration where the base cluster
is not consistent across different
classes
um online multi-calibration this extends
to it but without determinism adaptive
calibration or even just going Beyond
calibration for other group furnace I
don't have time to go on that I'm just
going to say that
this version The multi-distribution
Learning is one that if you try to solve
neither of the two Dynamics I gave you
is the right Dynamic to solve actually
so what you would have to do is a
totally different Dynamic which is the
third one and the third one says that
instead of doing no regret versus best
response both players should play No
Regret and if you do that you can
improve a lot of non-bounds and
multi-group learning group Dro
multi-grill fairness Collaborative
Learning and xyzing okay unfortunately I
don't have that much time but I'm happy
to take questions
any questions at this point
okay great let's thank you again
over we'll take over yeah
foreign